[Music]
well christmas is later this week but
santa claus arrived earlier today for
one las vegas family
their house is now a home thanks to the
walker furniture 27th annual home for
the holidays program
bianca holman was there as that family
got a very special delivery
this holiday is one to remember for one
east las vegas family of
six crystal luiza has five children all
under the age of ten
three boys ages one two and seven and
two girls
ages five and eight the kids share one
mattress and they don't have any
furniture
but now that's all changed beds
couches tables and chairs the way as a
family have what they need
thanks to the walker furniture's 27th
home for the holidays program
a co-worker at home depot nominated
floesa after learning about her living
situation
appreciate all her effort of doing this
for me writing that letter
like she did a big relief to my family
my kids are happy i'm happy and i really
appreciate it
makes it a little bit more difficult
during covert but the joy is still there
it always feels good to to do home for
the holiday
fellow home depot co-workers donated
clothes and gifts
and star nursery provided a treat and
decorations
this is the 27th year for the holiday
program this year
they will help more than 30 families
reporting in east las vegas b
oklahoman 8 news now